yes i won i wanted one and one and one
you're doing amazing sweetie yep that's
dream kardashian delivering one of kris
jenner's iconic quotes it makes me proud
the two team up for a new commercial and
to no one's surprise their chemistry is
priceless a positive attitude is
everything and you should always see the
glass as half full close enough it's
also a rare look at rob kardashian's
little girl so let's break it down hi
dream
thanks so much for squeezing me in this
morning the ad sees the two catching up
on video chat and dream came to play is
there anything you can't do wait till i
play whack-a-mole
dang oh my god this is so crazy that's
when little dream does a spot on
impression of chris yes i won i wanted
one and one and one you're doing amazing
sweetie yep even this little one is
aware of chris's iconic quote from
keeping up with the kardashians
and the commercial dives deeper into
famous kardashian moments so what's on
the agenda today boss reading a book
drawing a picture playing a game let's
play memory match
[Music]
i actually have a great memory i can
remember the names of all of my children
and almost all of my grandchildren yeah
we're pretty sure that's a reference to
chris's final appearance on the ellen
degeneres show i'm going to give you a
quiz because i think this is incredible
okay name all of your uh grandkids okay
and well chris came up a little short
mason penelope rain
north saint chicago sam
uh stormy
wolfe
um hold on dream
um
how many is that you're missing one help
me i'm missing one uh-huh i said dream
um true yes oh true i love you so much
yes
yes
back to her in dreams playdate so what's
the latest jerk living life yep that's
another nod to dreams famous family this
time it's aunt courtney and her status
update that went viral on tick tock my
vibe right now is just living life but
really though it's basically quartz
catchphrase at this point i'm just like
living life and
whatever happens happens fans haven't
seen too much of dream until now and for
the first time her personality is on
full display be a good sport because
winning isn't everything you want to go
again oh you better believe it not to
mention her sense of style life is a
game and there are a few lessons i've
learned along the way number one always
look at the world with rose-colored
glasses very chic dreamy but she's had
some moments to shine on social media
let's go girls
remember when dream and cousin true got
in on the we don't talk about bruno
trend
[Music]
it's as chris says in the commercial and
here's the most important lesson of all
nothing beats family
[Music]
you